todos irán a votar en costa rica y es
que el abstencionismo histórico es otra
de las problemáticas que enfrentan los
candidatos presidenciales en los últimos
comicios municipales de 2020 la
abstención fue del 62 al 19 por ciento
mucha gente
no hay ninguno que pueda hacer algo por
este país quizá las grandes campañas
electorales de las últimas semanas y el
llamado a las urnas el descontento
popular es patente entre los 35 millones
de electores con un 31 8% de indecisos
lo que una espera que el país mejore
pero en vez de mejorar se empeora porque
todos prometen pero no hacen nada en los
últimos comicios presidenciales de 2018
la extensión ismo en la segunda ronda ha
roto el 33 por ciento un fenómeno que
para los analistas tienen múltiples
causas como que en costa rica no existen
sanciones por no ir a votar el
desarraigo político el desempleo o la
corrupción política que ha generado una
falta de credibilidad entre los
costarricenses todo lo que los demás
partidos
han hecho y desecho ya no creemos
necesitamos actos contundentes que nos
demuestren que nos agarran la fe en que
si podemos confiar en alguien que nos
ayude a salir de donde estamos costa
rica se caracteriza por ser una de las
democracias más sólidas de américa
latina pero la pandemia de kobe 19 la
crisis económica y social han pasado
factura a la nación fracturando aún más
al apático electorado